good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone is
having an amazing day so far and it's
just about to get more amazing because
the toast is here and
it's october 1st wow there's so much
going on today it's a beautiful day here
in new york city
the toast is here it's thursday and
october 1st
yeah it's a it's a national feeling i'm
feeling good you know
it used to be a triggering day for me
but you know
what i was i was dealt you know a bad
hand
and i turned it into something positive
and now it's like a celebratory day it's
not really about me anymore it's not
about the money it's just about a day
it's kind of like national toast day
like it's just let's just remember like
we have a podcast with so many listeners
and people
love to just like laugh and be positive
with us and that's what this day
represents
totally but i do feel like the amount of
people who are watching now
who know what october 1st even is like
is very slim
we have our we have shedded our like
list like we actually like recycle
listeners it's crazy
not recycle like but you're right
shedding like we have a lot of listeners
who have been with us from the beginning
but like people come and go with the
toast so frequently sometimes the toast
comes in for a reason sometimes the
toast comes in for a season
you know yeah or like sometimes people
are like in places in their lives when
they need
the toes in them and they don't need the
toast so it's like we're in and out of
people's lives
to burn into the ground on their way out
on their way out so like it's
it's very possible that a lot of people
don't know the october first
significance um it's actually a morning
breath
concept which makes it like even more
archaic i'm really not in the mood to
like dive into it no but like we just
want to like october 1st recognition we
see you
claudia never got her money and that's
okay because we got
a barrel of laughs not only did i not
get my money in anticipation for me
getting my money i donated two hundred
dollars
to uh the toasters had to we like we put
it up for
auction like to the toasters like give
us best recommendations for charities to
give the 200
to and i ended up giving it to like a
new york-based charity and i never got
the 200
so i'm out 400 actually wow well you got
a 200
write-off yeah but you know that's true
maybe i like at the end of the day like
balanced it out evened out maybe
however write-offs work we have a busy
show
jam-packed lots of news some of it is
mindless
and some of it is not so you're just
gonna have to stay tuned to see what
happens
we have from our love island
correspondent huge recap of the finale
last night which i don't watch but you
will explain it to me and it will feel
like i was there
yes it will feel like you were there and
i also i just have to tell you a funny
story
oh so i went to dinner last night okay
and i was asking
it was like a mixed bag of people so i
was trying to like make interesting
conversation
and i was like what was the you know
what's your favorite movie what was the
last book you read
and like you would be shocked like i was
like the most well-read person at the
table like no one there really like had
read
um and i'm like yo you guys have got to
start eliza starts a rumor
i read it the other day i was really
being like and then someone
i like i felt really bad for lying i'm
like actually it was read to me but it
counts i read the book
yeah you did read the book you know what
goes down speaking of reading thank you
so much new
episode of the redheads drop today so
exciting
so special such a fun episode if you
haven't read the book you can still
listen to the episode because we're just
you know like
being chatty but you also could read the
book because it was a really good book
so check it out the redheads book club
you know that it's never too late to
become a redhead you can pick up any
book that we've ever read and then
listen to the corresponding episode
fall in love with the gals and then read
some more i follow obviously the red
heads on instagram because
i'm a supporter of the arts and you guys
refer to yourselves as the trbc well
trbc
um and i just love like some some
acronyms just work
tcby trbc and it really just like
i'm so proud of the acronym you've
created it's really impressive thank you
i don't use trbc that much but when i do
it's like
a punch you know
[Laughter]
no it honestly warms my heart some
acronyms just like
fit do you know what i mean yeah no they
like sound good
letters together and that's how i really
feel about tcby the country's best
yogurt
even though i don't really like what it
like tcby is a fabulous chain
might have gone out of business fabulous
chain of frozen yogurt um and i love
that it's an acronym like you want to go
to tcby
sure but then when i found out what it
stood for him like the country's best
yogurt
it's like no it's but it's tcby like
that's the word that's you know name
it's like a fun fact to know what it
stands for
right but all you need to know is tcpy
but i would say and by the way claudia i
would love to go to tcpy thank you for
asking i would
love to go to tcm maybe we'll go today
fine fine
twist my arm okay um okay so i feel like
we're busy like do we have anything else
we want to discuss
well i always like to share when i've
stumbled upon a content upper that
i think the group could benefit from
we can never not benefit from a content
upper so please i took your
recommendation if she's the man and it
literally lit up my night
right and i never said that the click
was a content ever so i'm not gonna put
that in that category but last night i
watched one of my
favorite movies bad teacher oh yeah
and it is just you guys
watch it it's on netflix it's so [ __ ]
good and like i've seen it so many times
and i know which parts make me laugh
and they still make me laugh do i hear
something crazy you've never seen it
i've never seen it i don't want to
overhype it because every time i like
tell you you're going to love something
and then you hate it well
claude claude you're in for a treat well
they played a lot on like bravo and
it's like don't watch it that way and
it's just i hate watching movies that
way they also always play the holiday
and that's when like they start to ruin
movies when they put like so many
commercials on it's like on ian it's
like what's watching and they cut out
like some of the
scenes and also like it's less graphic
you know they change the language yeah
it's not like punchy like that so don't
watch it in that way
watch it on netflix i never get tired of
watching it it is just
so funny she is so so good i love
cameron yes now today i want to become a
teacher you should
i know like the movie makes you want to
be a teacher so teach the arts and like
when they are at the cowboys saloon
listening to period five
um and they just have that like teacher
camaraderie
i'm like i want to be a teacher teacher
camaraderie is so real
like the teacher's lounge just pop in
the teacher's lounge if i i honestly
would become a teacher just for the
lounge
except i heard that um in our old high
school which is like when i think of
high school like i just imagine my high
school obviously
and um i heard that they actually
renovated the teacher's lounge and had
to make it into like offices and
classrooms
so it's like the teachers have been put
out where do the teachers lounge
i don't know huh devastating budget cuts
budget cuts
yeah that ain't right the teachers got a
lounge the teachers deserve a lounge
a hundred percent like you can't be with
that like camper energy
wrong and not have a place to have a
reprieve and not have a safe space and
honestly as a kid i never understood
like why they were so secretive like you
couldn't even look in the teacher's
lounge like yeah there's like a sheet
like a
uh shade on the window and like when
teachers go in like they open the door
slightly and like sneak in like it's
like this
oasis and and i never understood why
they were so like top secret agent about
it
but now as an adult it's like obviously
you don't want the kid energy sneaking
in
yeah no it could seep in from any
crevice and you've just got to
corner them all off 100 it's like an
infestation
yeah yeah so they gotta fumigate the
place they must so bad teacher if you're
looking for a content opera i watched it
before i went to bed last night went to
bed with a smile on my face
oh that's lovely i went to bed on my
thoughts i went to bed like just a
little drunk
oh also lovely yes speaking of thotch
house paceman
he's good he's really just like in a
positive happy inner peaceful place
and once again he's just so busy you
know like lighting up the lives of
millions of
millions of americans that is what he
does and we miss him today
but at least it's not hump day and so
like that would be a devastation if
he were to miss a hump day like
yesterday it would be a huge loss you're
right
but um i understand why he can't be here
today and
i'm just going to move on from it
because i don't want to dwell you know
yeah no i mean
you brought it up so i know i just like
i like to check in with him
of course
um i think without further ado without
further discussion of yaranti
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
oh no oh no
are you okay what happened
i think i fainted it must be the rdh
allow me to grab my medicine
all right let's see if it's too much
jackie i got this you have the cure
today's episode is brought to you by
honey these days it feels like online
shopping is the only shopping we really
do
and that's today's sponsor honey it's
the free browser extension that scours
the internet for promo codes and
automatically applies the best ones
available at checkout
honey is basically your online shopping
best friend here's how it works
you get honey on your computer for free
and two easy clicks by
going to joinhoney.com toast then when
you're checking out
on one of its over 30 000 supported
sites honey will pop up and all you have
to do is click apply coupons it's
literally the easiest thing ever
if you go to joinhoney.com toast you can
get the honey browser extension
for free you don't have to do anything
else and then every time you shop at
bloomingdale sephora revolve like they
literally work with every website on the
face of the earth over 30 000
um a little box will come up and honey
you'll be like do you want us to help
you save money and you say sure
and then it like runs this little thing
and all these different promo codes they
try
and they find you the best promo code on
the internet available and it's
literally the most premium thing ever
and if you're not doing it you're
actually just wasting money
um they have found it's over 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings
they support all kinds of retailers from
tech gaming sites fashion brands
delivery
beauty i use a lot um it's super simple
so if you have a computer honey should
be on it it's free and works with
whatever browser
you use you can get honey for free today
at joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com
toast wow i feel better i got the wind
knocked out of me god
the rdh flare-ups have been um really
really
uh really tough to get through and i
just have to say i think that um
we have had in the last few months like
a wave of new toasters because
i'm like getting inundated with messages
like what does rdh mean right
so please explain to the class well i
was having a hard time explaining it
because it's like kind of a long thing
and someone commented on the chosen
instagram like what does rdh mean and
this other toaster wrote like a very
eloquent um response and i posted that
response on my instagram story so if
you're looking for it go check that out
but also long story short rdh stands for
remiss
devastated and heartbroken and it
started out as every time i was about to
jump into the stories claudia would let
me know that she would be vermis
devastated in her program if she didn't
share the sponsor of the day
it's it's honestly like it's a burden
like it weighs very heavy on me and i
feel i have a responsibility and if i
don't tell everyone who the sponsor is
like
i really would feel remiss i would feel
devastated i would even feel not to be
dramatic heartbroken
right so now every day like until you
alleviate that burden you have a case of
the rdh
and sometimes it takes over it it's so
overwhelming like you have no idea what
it's like to just like
shoulder this burden no i i mean i watch
you go through it every day
and so i've seen firsthand thank you i'm
i'm so glad you're here for me wow warm
[ __ ] cold i'm actually very warm today
as well
so i'm like aware of i mean it's
emanating from it's hot as [ __ ] in here
it's hot as [ __ ] i'm wearing a jacket
it's also like not
cold outside you know i think our studio
is like the temperature that it is
outside well because we have like big
windows and it's kind of a small place
like it's [ __ ] hot
big windows in a small place
is that a song big love in a small town
lady a
obscure reference obscure because not
only is it like
a random song by a random group it's
also you didn't even see it you changed
the words you got a
big window
small please okay okay let's move on
okay first story really really sad news
chrissy teigen and john legend suffer
pregnancy laws quote
we will always love you chrissy teigen
and john legend are mourning the loss of
their son one month after announcing
their pregnancy
the couple shared the sad news on
wednesday revealing that her bleeding
couldn't be stopped despite bags and
bags of blood transfusions
quote we are shocked and in the kind of
deep pain you only hear about the kind
of pain we've never felt before we were
never able to stop the bleeding and give
our baby the fluids he needed
despite bags and bags of blood
transfusions it just wasn't enough
chrissy wrote in a lengthy emotional
instagram post
we never decide on our baby's names
until the last possible moment after
they're born just before we leave the
hospital
but we for some reason had started to
call this little guy in my belly jack
so he will always be jacked to us jack
works so hard to be a part of our little
family
and he will be forever this is just
absolutely horrible story and i feel
like one that like
just everyone is like shook by yeah and
i was in
on the way here like in a taxi looking
at her instagram and the pictures that
were taken and then like reading
people's comments like
it it's just i literally started crying
in the back of a cab it's just like it's
so
so sad it's so sad she was like a little
over 20 weeks
and it's like of course like at the
beginning of pregnancy i feel like
there's always like trepidation you have
to be you don't want to be superstitious
and i don't know 20 weeks it's like you
feel like you might be in the clear and
it's just
so sad so sad so painful the pictures
are so emotional
and i mean so many people are like in
celebrities are reaching out
and supporting her and which is
beautiful to see i just i feel so
heavily for their family yeah the
picture that actually like really really
made me sad was her getting an epidural
because it's like at that point you know
it's like not going well and you have to
go through
the whole thing yeah and that type of
procedure that you get that epidural
like you're expecting you know
a baby at the end and that doesn't
happen it's just really really sad and
this is like
i was actually really surprised with how
much she shared yeah like
in the caption and the photos but she's
so open and and i feel like that's
that can be a burden too it's like you
want to share all the positive and then
it's like
and you don't have to share the negative
and i think it was like really really
brave of her because i think a lot of
people
go through things like this and they
feel like alone and isolated and like
not that many people talk about it so i
actually
think a lot of people really appreciated
her being so open and transparent about
it but i was like wow like
i mean i could never do that no to like
go through it and then also to open
yourself up
right like to be like in support of
others
right it's just and people on the
internet are [ __ ] evil and vicious
yeah and you like you would think like
some of the comment like i can yeah no
well
we're just thinking of her family during
this time and
just a terrible story emotional
um okay switching gears a little uh
seagram's heiress claire bomfriend
sentenced to more than six years for her
role in the next scene
sex cold so claudia's favorite losery
cult oh my god nexium
is being brought to justice and one of
the
major participants claire bronfman was
sentenced to six years for her role in
the sex slave cult
you know what i feel like there are a
lot of people responsible for it um
and if you're watching the documentary
it's actually really hard to dis
like make the difference between like
those who are responsible and like those
who are victims because at the end of
the day it's like when we're talking
about allison mack it's like
she was recruited in the cult she fell
prey to the cult but then she
[ __ ] went all the way to the top and
started this
part of the part of uh ep esp
which was like the really problematic
call like the rest of the group it was
like a little weird that all these
adults were like hanging out and
spending money like being friends but at
the end of the day it wasn't illegal it
was just like a weird thing
but the the problematic part of esp was
jeunesse which is started by allison
mack wow
and so to me it was like this cult
preyed on people who were
you know down or having a hard time or
low self-esteem and
uh what's the word i'm looking for
exploited that
and got them to join the cult for years
and years and years there were some
successful people in it but they were
all like deeply
um like like like they oh i mean
everyone has something in them that they
want to fix and that's what
nexium like really preyed on in people
and so
it was shocking at like how well-run
next cm was and like their facilities
and this
they literally owned a town in albany
and they got the dalai lama to come and
it's like
how does this group of losers do that
and it's because of claire
and her sister sarah bronfman like they
were the ones financing it they were the
ones with the connections to the dalai
lama
like they were the ones who legitimized
it and so to me that's like such
like they're like keith rainier is the
guy who started and like he's the worst
in all of this but they're really up
there for me like
they're the ones who really made it
possible keith winery didn't have a pot
to piss in yeah like people
make it possible for him to ascend to
the level of power that he did right
and not only that it was like so they
according to the documentary like they
were
keith renery got like a lot of bad press
like it's not like this didn't go
unnoticed like there was this huge
article in forbes about it and it said
that clarence sarah bronfman's dad was
behind
a lot of the bad press because he was
like why are my daughters these freaks
involved in a cult and so he was doing
everything he could to protect his
daughter and like exploit like this man
um so they had to like really
overcompensate because they wanted to
impress keith
and they were like yeah we're really
rich but like keith
is we're not bringing value because
we're the ones our dad is the one
making this seem illegitimate so they
worked overtime to get
the private plane to go see the dalai
lama and it's like you're [ __ ] losers
like
two people who grew up with everything
they inherited 250 million dollars these
girls and it's like that's what you
[ __ ] spend it on
buy a jet like a normal [ __ ] person
yeah
that's the way this part of the
documentary like bothered me the most
did you finish the documentary so it's
episodic and so another one was released
on sunday i haven't seen it yet
are you enjoying it because at first you
weren't i wasn't about you
this story well here's why why i love it
is why i also didn't enjoy the
documentary it's because there's so much
hype
you think of it like scientology which
really scientology is like the most
star-studded
group there's a lot it's very
interesting nexium
like really granted like who's ever
doing the marketing for the nexium
scandals doing a good job
because you think it's like this
celebrity salacious there is not one
famous person in it like
i can't stress that enough allison mack
is the most famous person on it
and if you never told me she was in
smallville i never would have known she
literally looks like she could be
anything she's a barista she's a pilot
like she could be anything
yeah i i agree with that they do have
good they have good pr
but the movie i mean the documentary is
definitely getting better because the
intricacies like this bronfman
element are so fascinating because it's
like
can you imagine just like being born
with everything you've ever wanted like
they were talking about like their
pedigree oh i moved across the country
and
started writing courses like it's just
like this idyllic life and i know that
no one's life is perfect but
to be given everything like from the
start of your life and like this is what
you do with it it's like
it's such a disgrace it's like humanity
at its worst
yeah that's the part that like i can't
wrap my head around of course like the
branding like that's crazy
but when when the women who were victims
of the cult you think like that could
never happen to me
you you hear it it just happened so fast
yeah then it's like literally takes one
thing for you to realize like holy [ __ ]
i'm in a cult like
and so that i can understand i can
understand like being
you know in a place in your life where
you're vulnerable and like this powerful
group thinks they're going to help you
and like
next thing you know 12 years have passed
and like you gave this cult your life i
i can actually understand that and i can
see it happening i can't relate to
someone who literally has been given
everything their entire lives and
inherited 250 million dollars for
something they've never even done like
they didn't work on seagram's you know
like
that level of wealth and to do that and
hurt people like
that to me is the the worst part of
nexium and that's what the documentary
episode like four or five started to get
into and that's where i think it got
really interesting just like hearing
about them and like hearing them do
interviews on like local albany radio
talking about keith ranieri it's like
these [ __ ] losers like
it should it it's the loser cult like i
just can't use another word i'm sorry
i'm
repetitive but loser
excuse me excuse me whatever major loser
okay next story in the story of the week
our girl of the week demi lovato
has released her ballads still have me
after her max eric breakup what are what
are the messages
so i listened to it and it's um
it's me it's full of message it's not
like a bang or about
oh okay it's because i think you know
she obviously just wrote it in her diary
and then sang it yeah but she's saying
i'm still
i'm still a mess and i'm still broken
but i'm finding my way back
and it feels like someone's stolen all
the light i ever had
it it hurts to breathe i don't have much
but at least i still have me
and that's all i need oh that's sweet i
really like that message i like that
message too i like that she's not being
like salacious like
no like you stole my car you know what i
mean like she could have done
yeah no she's just being honest because
i think we can all imagine how she feels
right now like
obviously she's embarrassed but i'm sure
she's also heartbroken like she thought
she might marry this was her fiance like
you're still sad so like to go from that
level of partnership to
being on your own and also realizing
like this person was most likely using
you
right and to sue him for what he really
is which is
ugly it hurts yeah you know what i feel
like now that i didn't realize it until
you just said this i feel like what
happened between max eric
and demi lovato is like a celebrity
especially a female celebrity like a
powerful woman's like worst nightmare
it's like at the end of the day it's
like you realize this relationship the
entire time like you were probably being
used and that's like always what
celebrities are looking out for whether
it's in partners friendships like they
they're they're powerful famous rich
people
and that's what a user a social climber
likes mac eric should look for
and so to make in the last few days like
have the realization that like
literally your worst fear is what
actually happened to you like that sucks
yeah yeah and it's it's a lot to process
so
yeah we're with demi on this one of
course we are like
i don't know how you couldn't no no but
like not
just like throwing you know her into
like
being able to separate like demi from
max you know not just like the two of
them
up in flames do you know what i mean i
mean i always support demi like i think
she's literally the best disney channel
star like
i wouldn't have said it when i was in
the disney world like i was like hannah
montana ride or die
but now of all those girls who have
grown up and become huge stars like i
think she's really like the best role
model
yeah in a lot of ways i agree she's so
open about
like her journey to sobriety and the ups
and downs that come with
being sober um
i don't know i just feel like she's
really body confident like i love her
yeah no
she she really does set a great example
she's very real like she doesn't
you know you know what's going on in her
life and this is it and this is it
it's tough so the song is pretty good
check it out oh i will
next up kylie jenner's first day of
school outfit for stormy webster will
grab
any teacher's attention so stormy
webster had her first day of school
yesterday which was just so exciting for
stormy fans everywhere
um also what was extremely exciting was
her air maze to go kelly
backpack which reportedly retails for
twelve thousand dollars
that's [ __ ] crazy and i was actually
when i saw this picture and like the
articles about her backpack
i'm like i need to talk to the teacher
so it's like stormy his homework
does she touch the cali bag and it's
like swimming let me put that in your
bag for you or like
destroy me put it in her own bag like i
need the logistics of being a teacher
with a student who has a 12 000
backpack when this when the child's five
years old this isn't like a high school
student you know
yes and also like the oh the mechanics
of opening and closing
that bag are hard our like more
difficult thing you're just standard
zipper so
like i just i'm worried your things are
gonna fall out if it's not properly
secured
right and it's like pens and pencils do
you think stormy has a bodyguard at
school
oh i don't know they're probably so
extra like there might be someone
waiting on side i don't think he goes
into the classroom with her but this is
also her first day of school like
they're figuring it out yeah but i'm
sure like
kylie's just doing like whatever kim and
courtney's kids do do you think they all
go to the same school
i do i think they all go to the same
school i don't know they're such
different parents and that's really what
we would say you live in literally the
same
street yeah how many schools are there
for celebrity children in the area
i don't know it's calabasas i'm sure
there's a lot but like i'm sure
you know now stormy has like eight
cousins
they've been through the school system
i'm sure they figured out at this point
like which is the best school i mean
they could literally just like have
their own school
property maybe they have started their
own school because they that would be
smart they have enough kids for a
classroom
the kids would maybe grow up to be like
a little strange but
honestly if you're that rich and like i
don't know sending your
your kid off to school like and then
like
you just don't know if like the other
kids are like taking pictures of her
like it would freak me out
yeah yeah i just can't believe it
stormy's going to school
already you know like it's just boring
she she was just born it's just a marker
of like how quick
time is passing i was in a cab literally
yesterday
watching the youtube video where kylie
confirmed her pregnancy like that was
yesterday
yeah how was it literally five years ago
years ago and
i feel like when i look at stormy i feel
the way like a part of the way that i'm
sure kylie feels towards her which is
like
she's growing up so fast and you're so
proud of her i'm so proud of her and now
she's like this
little educated queen
and with her backpack which was just the
cutest thing and love to see it
we do love to see growth i just want to
wish stormy well on her second day
now it's her second day and i hope the
first day was good because you know
first days of school can be really
really tough really tough like
making friends is so hard and like i
want to put too much pressure on story
me but like
the friends you make in school like at
the beginning like become your friends
for life so it's like you want to pick a
good group so
she better have had a good day yesterday
right right things could go south
right but she has her cousins so like
that's so fun yeah and if she is in
school
with her cousins that's chicago and true
right and the triplets like they're just
gonna
run this school yeah and it's actually
really sweet how penelope and north are
so close
yeah my heart you know hurts for me soon
that there's no one his age
he's a trailblazer he is he's gonna be
like the cool cousin who's like smoking
pot you know
yeah no or like giving them rides places
and like all their friends well i think
he's so cute and they'll be like mason
could you drive us today and he's like
guys i'm busy
fine yeah no it's mad cute and
that's a show like i will watch like the
kardashian junior
in high school yeah keeping up with the
juniors yeah
okay keeping up with the jenner juniors
or just
junior jenners is a good show yeah but
like it doesn't apply to
some of them are dyslexics it's tough
fifth and final story your favorite girl
krishelle stouse
is um talking about her divorce she says
seeing her ex justin hartley date again
was painful
but she's excited to move on who's he
dating well he was
like spotted a few months after the
divorce with his co-star
and so makes you think but christelle
stouse is back on the market and ready
to mingle
last november the actress and reality
star was left heartbroken when her
husband justin hartley suddenly filed
for divorce
ending their marriage over a text
message she tells people i've had to
start over so many times in my life i
always know how to look at the bright
side because there's been a lot of dark
um while still processing her shattered
marriage she was also dealing with
another devastating blow and her
mother died of lung cancer and then her
dad did too oh my god
within months um and she talks about
watching
justin move on she said i feel like
anybody would be heartbroken to see how
quickly or easily
you are replaced of course that's going
to sting
yeah i mean i always i had a dream like
last week
that ben and i decided to have an open
marriage and like i couldn't get a date
but ben
obviously could and he was like i'm
going to see this girl morgan like we're
going to get ice cream and like i
the rage i felt like in my dream
i feel like very protective it's like
okay if i die like ben has to die too
because he cannot date anyone ever like
i just like that feeling and like that's
so heightened like you get divorced and
then like
divorce is sad because like you go from
being together to being alone and then
it's like you have to see them dating
someone like
that would drive me [ __ ] nuts yeah oh
my god like
i don't justice for everyone who's ever
been divorced yeah
um she also talked about changing her
last name so quickly
oh by the way i have so much respect for
her yeah she said
um quote i'm not trying to be somewhere
i'm not wanted
oh that's so good yeah i respect that
so hard like yeah like right before and
like she had gotten famous because
season one she was answering the phone
krishna hartley like she had gotten
famous already with the name michelle
hartley and like a lot of people are
hesitant
to change their name when they're like
famous or becoming famous because it's
hard enough to get known as
christelle stouse now we have to get
known as you know it's like two
different things she really did it like
i know her as chris
stouse now right also i read an article
um about the origin of her name do you
know the story
yes oh my god it's a beautiful story her
mom was like out of gas a shell gas
station
getting something and when she went into
labor and it was like this a whole
dramatic thing this guy had to help her
and the guy who helped her was named
chris so was chris
from the shell station
i love that it's interesting it's
interesting
yeah i love the name with a story i love
a name with a story do you have a story
no that's i'm just jackie yeah you know
like i wasn't it's not i think they had
a different name plan for me
when i arrived they said i was like so
stunning like we're
really similar to claudia schiffer yeah
that they actually like they had no
choice but to name me claudia
yeah that makes sense i heard that if
you were a boy you were going to be
named theo
i thought you were going to say claude
oh well of course blood
um i never felt like as cool as i did in
our class when like we learned about
claude monet and i was like cunningham
you know him my god it's my dad
i can't should we dive into our reality
tv recap we should dive
head first right in because i have much
to say well today's reality tv recap is
very appropriately brought to you
by click bait with bachelor nation
everyone loves a good bit of gossip
go inside the juiciest stories on click
bait with with bachelor nation
host tasha adams hannah ann sluss
and joe ambly know what it's like to
live in the spotlight
they've seen that fame can be mean being
praised adored and sabotaged
sometimes all in the same day true on
clickbait
they share what they've learned from
their wild days at the bachelor mansion
to bring you a new kind of celebrity
news podcast
each week they break down the biggest
stories in pop culture dissecting every
outrageous headline
debunking every rumor and sorting
through what's truly clickbait and
what's real
and with these three the arguments about
hollywood scandals will be as dramatic
as the headlines themselves
every week features a different
celebrity guest dishing unfiltered
opinions on the gossip of the day
you won't want to miss these hilarious
explosive revelations
subscribe to click bait with bachelor
nation on apple podcast or spotify
or listen ad free with wunderyplus in
the wondery app
again that's clickbait with bachelor
nation tasha hannah anne joe amable
it sounds like such a good podcast and
the concept is actually a great idea for
a podcast because there's so much
clickbait out there and it's like i'm
constantly falling prey on
like random websites to fake news no
totally
um okay so tell me about love island
everyone was rooting for this couple and
i think they won right christine and
caleb
they won no one else could have one like
one they were just
worlds above everyone else and
the entire i mean i got like my audience
like reviews from twitter like everyone
was just like
here for caleb and justine like their
love story was so beautiful and some of
the other couples you know they meet
each other and they're like i'm
attracted to you i'm attracted to you
and
we're gonna like be in a relationship
now and then things happen
everyone has bumps in the road but they
came together like
slowly at first friends at first and
like he was with another girl and she
like
just put herself out there and let him
know that she was into him and he
switched and and
started um coupling up is the term
with justine and like from there just
like blossomed into
such a beautiful love story two nights
ago they did like
these big dates you know like bachelor
style fan like not fantasy suite but
like right so they took a
helicopter over grand canyon west and
then they landed
in the grand canyon and had a picnic and
it was so beautiful
and they told each other that they loved
each other which is like a big deal for
love island i think some people throw it
around because you know maybe if they
know that it'll help them win
it'll help them win um but like in that
moment like
i felt that they were in love and i was
like they're gonna say it right
that's crazy that's a crazy date i don't
know how you transition back to like
normal dates at mcdonald's like after
that
yeah but all the cup so there's a final
four couples and they all go
on really extravagant dates on this last
day throughout the season they like
literally have they set up a
table in the pool and yeah they go on
like okay dates but these dates were
just like
on another level like one couple took a
ferrari down um
one some like nevada avenue at like
canyon sort of avenue it has a name and
apparently it's really cool that's a
sickening date
yeah another couple they got all the
whole caesar's um theater
empty well also because there's a
pandemic right and so they had like they
cleared everyone out dinner in there and
there were like some dancers dancing
like really sickening dates but caleb's
and justine's was just
the best a helicopter to the middle of
grand canyon and like then having a
picnic
and telling each other that they love
each other so sweet the ferrari one
sounds really good too
yeah that's where reality like it's
sometimes it's not surprising like that
so many reality tv couples fail
when you fall in love in like this
idyllic setting where everything is
taken care of for you and then it's like
you get home it's like where do you want
to eat i don't know where do you want to
eat like yes
how can you not hate the person yes but
like on love island they're mostly just
in the villa like right
and it's not that ritzy glitz like it is
on the bachelors so
to have these like big dates is really
exciting um
and so there were four couples left
again and runner up was
sally and johnny who throughout like you
would have probably thought they were
going to win until i told you about casa
more where they brought
they separated the guys the girls they
brought in for and johnny and
sally and johnny were like the strongest
couple at the time and johnny just like
went so hard with this other girl
and when he came back he told sally but
like kind of glazed over it
and then other guys came in and told her
had seen watched it on tv and told her
and so like she had never seen it she
didn't know what to believe and it
really just like threw a wrench
in their relationship and that was
around the time i was catching up on
twitter and like
the way people on twitter hated johnny i
like i would have had no idea i would
have thought that like people were
really rooting for them but then i
started to see like everything he was
doing is like
fake you started to see him for who he
truly was which is
ugly um and then the other two couples
of one of the couples laurel and
carrington who i didn't mind at the end
like carrington had just been like a
little too like fake and wishy-washy
right people really did not like him and
then moira
and calvin moira moira it's crazy
um they really came together by the end
people were getting like kind of tired
of her because she would like be with
like these great guys and be like i'm
not feeling it and even her and calvin
were coupled up in the middle and they
like they weren't feeling it so they
broke up but then at the end like they
were
legitimately in a relationship but so
justine and calvin were just
constantly falling more and more in love
throughout the season
and it was a beautiful beautiful thing
to watch they're the first black couple
to win love island
and to watch their love play out i don't
know and i watched last season and it
was really good and i feel like more
people are watching this season because
um
there's less to do and it's a show
that's on every single night for an hour
and it's really premium like the way
that they package it
and i just feel like watching the finale
last night and
watching them win it was just a really
beautiful moment i literally had chills
up my entire body what channel is it on
cbs
got it i mean every night that's like
such a like a crazy amount like of
content yeah i never watched it like
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday sunday but
i saturday sunday two yeah it's on
sunday so
they take one or two nights a week off i
think but i would just like watch
six episodes at a time and when you're
into a show it is really nice
yeah so even though the season like kind
of started off
slow by the end like i think that caleb
and justine are one of the
best love stories on reality tv that
like we have seen
what are the odds you think that they'll
make it in the real world i think the
odds are very very high
i really do and when i was watching last
night i'm like all these couples are
gonna make it of course
but i don't i don't know i think that
they will make it out look forward to
seeing how the other couples do
but it's just it was it was really
it turned out to be a really great
season so it's just crazy that there are
so many like new
bachelor type of shows or just like
coupling up shows like with love is
blind too out to handle
we've just like so many more like future
influencers like in
our rotation um and there actually feel
like there are a lot of couples now who
are still together
lauren and cameron are still together
from uh
love is blind i don't think anyone's
together from two out to handle right no
i don't think the show
wrong yeah no having watched shoe hot to
handle and then going back to love is
blind it was really confusing cause i
was like they were kissing and i'm like
you're not allowed
yeah like there were so many rules at
each show that you got confused watching
but i think i liked love is blind way
better yeah well it was more
it had more substance yeah like i
actually cried at some of it oh
barrett amber and barnett amber and
barnett i love how you knew what i was
talking about yeah because i was waiting
for you to say that they were still
together so i remembered their names i
just saw they're on tick tock now and
they were like are putting out some q
contact they're actually
really cute also with love island the
winners do get a hundred thousand
dollars and then at the end there's one
last test to see if like you want to
split the money or if one person's to
keep it because like then you could like
if you
wait sorry start again at the end of
love island the winning couple wins a
hundred thousand dollars each wear
center together
well they each so this is how it goes
the host gives
two people a card one of our cards says
a hundred thousand dollars the other
person says zero dollars
the person who says the couple they're
and they're a couple the person who has
the hundred thousand dollars decides if
they want to keep the hundred thousand
for themselves
or split it so of course caleb split it
oh my god that's a
terrible like johnny johnny was like and
he's the one who was like everyone's
kind of out on at this point he was like
bro you should keep it like kidding and
it's like you aren't kidding
no you weren't getting like if so johnny
and sally had one like imagine if a
couple you thought this entire time was
like
in love and then it turned out that this
person was just really here for the
money
oh has that happened i don't know i
there's a lot of seasons of love island
uk i've never watched them so i don't
know if that's happened or maybe it's
like maybe they really did like this
other person but they don't think it's
gonna work out so let me at least get an
extra 50k right so alex stewart who is a
toaster
she was on love island u.s she was on
loveland u.s last season which was the
first season of us
and she came in second runner up yes and
they're not together anymore
that guy and the winning couple's not
together anymore either right so we'll
see this time next year
who's together yes we will so is the
couple that came in second
last night still together technically
yeah and even
third and fourth like they say that
they're gonna leave the villain i don't
care that i didn't win like i got my
girl i got my guy
and i had sure you know so and i'm sure
maybe they feel that way right now
because also like when you're in the
villa you only have eyes for this other
person like it's like
um you know
villa goggles right so and also you
don't know how they behave in the real
world like everyone's on their best
behavior
when they're in a villa there's no other
actually there are a lot of other
options and temptations
but also like america's watching you
interesting sounds like a fabulous show
i feel like i was there
yeah it was really good it ended on such
a beautiful note
and just the show is just really well
done so i'm really happy for caleb and
justine
and i look forward to watching their
love continue
we have um we've done all we needed to
do today you know but there does feel
like something is missing and
it's that sense of that little sequoia
of mindlessness and i think it
it might be time for some mindless news
um and it is a thursday so i feel like
it would be really really like
really inappropriate of me not to
mention that kelly's mindless news is
brought to you by
thursday boots just in time for the
start of boot season we received a few
of the new releases from our friends at
thursday boots
as a quick reminder thursday boots is
the new york city-based startup brand
that designs really really comfortable
high-quality boots and sells them at the
best direct-to-consumer prices
they handcraft their boots in the north
same north american and european
facilities as brands that charge two to
four times the price
but by cutting out the retail markups
they offer the highest quality boots at
a very accessible price
if there was ever a time to invest in
more comfortable boots it's now
i mean perfect timing i've started to
now like take out my boots i'm wearing
boots probably every day
um my favorite over-the-knee boots are
last season thursday boots and i got so
many compliments on them so i can't wait
for all the compliments i'm gonna get
this year totally um if you want fast
fashion or shoes that rarely make it out
of your closet don't shop at thursday
boots thirsty boots is an investment in
comfort timeless styles and staples that
will last
for years you deserve more comfortable
boots without the high retail markups
because thursday boots is all about
year-round honest prices at the lowest
sustainable market possible
they never have sales or do discounts
but they are giving our listeners a free
two-day shipping on their first order
and they always offer free returns and
exchanges so you have absolutely nothing
to lose by trying out your first pair of
thursday boots
go to thursdayboots.com toast for
the free two-day shipping again that's
thursdayboots.comtoast
and you can have a pair on your doorstep
before next thursday they actually have
amazing shipping
um that's thursday boots
o o t t-h-u-r-s-d-a-y-b-o-o-t-s dot com
toast for free two day shipping plus
free returns and exchanges you wanna
look fly this season
get your thursday boots yeah if you're
looking for a new pair of boots for the
season
head over to thursday boots they've got
all the greatest styles okay it's time
for some
kelly's mindless news like the 4th of
july
oh that felt so good it's been so long
that felt so good morning millennials
two days kelly's mindless news is
brought to you by hello magazine which
is i believe a big uh british tabloid
and they are
really like spearheading for a while it
was like good housekeeping people
magazine
but they are the spearheaders of
mindlessness oh interesting after
explaining
this [ __ ] international after extensive
research i have come to the conclusion
that hello magazine
is probably the worst offender in the
case of kelly
versus the people kelly vs
people's time kelly's first the people's
saturday
here's the headline kelly ripa shares
stunning
pool photo from inside her garden in the
hamptons
so before i read this is a headline what
are you imagining on the photo
i'm imagining a stunning pool like a
truly stunning pool photo
inside a garden hamptons like not a
something that i would ever think to
write an article on but like really a
beautiful pool like she's a hampton
and what do you think what elements do
you think are in
the picture so i'm gonna say like pool
from a distance like not super up close
with like beautiful floral arrangements
maybe like a ripe tomato okay so let me
show you how they describe
this photo okay kelly ripa is currently
spending her time between her homes in
the hamptons and manhattan
while husband mark consuelos is working
in vancouver but before mark and swift
yes but before mark consuelos left back
in the summer the live with kelly and
reinstar shared the most
incredible photo of her husband relaxing
in the family's
luxury swimming pool in their garden
the actress took to instagram to share a
snapshot of mark relaxing in the water
and captioned it
sunday vibes hashtag daddy
fans wait to one side of the pool were
several lounge chairs
and the picture also gave a glimpse of
the family's perfectly
manicured lawn fans were quick to
comment on the picture with one writing
damn that's a nice pool
while another wrote what a view
a third even added the hamptons pool
water is so
refreshing now i'm going to show you the
picture we will have posted it on our
instagram by now so make sure to check
it out
this is the gorgeous unbelievable
show-stopping photo of kelly's backyard
the garden
the pool okay
you guys it's literally a picture of
mark and swaidles in the pool like so
close up i can bare i could literally
barely see the yard and the nerve that
they have to start this headline
in her garden like are you serious it's
this is what they need on that clickbait
podcast
that is so crazy i don't see one flower
yeah
no flowers and you oh you could see a
lounge chair you could see literally
like the legs of a couple of wooden
lounge chairs oh my god that is so
crazy and this is why we do the work
that we do to uncover
the mindlessness and the conspiracy
behind kelly ripa
and the insane amount of press that she
gets for seemingly no reason
yeah and you know what if she's gonna
get all this press for like these
instagram photos like she should be
using jackie o'flow oh her instagram not
to mention
it's like awesome she uses the instagram
filters that are pre-provided
as an x-pro for sure and i feel like she
maybe even took the picture
in the instagram app yeah like that's
how it's so low quality no that's how
little she cares like she knows it's
gonna get written up like
bare like she's just phoning it in it's
isn't that crazy
that's really crazy it really never
ceases to amaze me
i think i really i really try to be like
okay if there's like a stunning picture
of kelly ripa's pool and
her nice looking husband is in it and
there's beautiful flowers like okay
sure you want to write about it that's
newsworthy but this blurry
like tragedy of a photo
is not newsworthy and i think that you
know it's been a really long time since
we did a segment kelly's mindless news
kmn
um it's been a while but it's not
because there hasn't been news but it's
just because i feel like we were like
going in on her a little bit too much
but like there has been especially in
quarantine
so much mindless news from kelly like
it's astonishing it is astonishing
and also like you have to slow down on
reporting on it because
it's so mindless you know you need to be
more mindful
it's it's but it's also like so mindless
but also so overwhelming at the same
time do you know what i mean
yeah and that's the power of kelly and
her mindless
news like the 4th of july hope you
enjoyed that i hope you enjoyed the show
anything else we want to talk about wrap
up there is no show tomorrow jackie and
i
are road tripping road tripping
sometimes
we gotta listen to that when we road
trip today i think we're also gonna film
a patreon video
of the trip that we're gonna be
traveling on the road for
no you know i thought we were doing oh
yes i brought my little tripod for the
car
amazing yeah uh a video that we i mean
you guys we've spoken about it so we can
share
what we will try and film on our way
back from our
road tripping sometimes
um the the fast food video where we try
all the fastest it's a mukbang
yeah i'm actually really excited to get
my hands on another impossible whopper
we're gonna check out all the local
stops the wendy's the mcdonald's the
burger king i absolutely just love fast
food so much i was having this
conversation and maybe even
have even said it on the toast multiple
times but i can't believe there are
people who like travel to michelin star
restaurants in paris and like think it's
the best meal they've ever had
when literally the best meal is at your
local mcdonald's yeah
i can't imagine that food gets any
better than mcdonald's i just can't and
maybe that's the
naivete in me but it's
premium cuisine it's premium cuisine and
so i'm really excited to film that video
gotta stay hungry for it gotta stay
hungry for it and that's all she wrote
yep thank you guys so much for listening
to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the what just if you're upset
that this episode is ending which i can
understand it could be upsetting it's
very traumatized there's two places i
want to send you first place
morning toast patreon because we
recorded a podcast episode yesterday
where claudia and i took a
best friend's quiz to see how well i
really know her and the questions were
really interesting
very deep jackie knows a lot about me
but then there are some things that
i didn't know about you and and i
learned today so head over to
patreon.comtoast
and if you want more content head over
to the redheads book club we have a new
episode out
it's me and the gals and we're breaking
down the unravelling of this are you in
the jazzy house it's me and jazzy
and we're also talking about all the
other books that we read this month also
i shared with the redheads it was the
redheads exclusive but i hit my 2020
reading goal
which was only october i know which was
50 books
and that was the goal i set out like
before there was a pandemic that
made me be home all the time reading but
[ __ ] wild i read 50 books this year
so far
and i read eight last month i need to
actually get a life but um
i'm sharing with you all my favorites
that i read and so are the other girls
so if you're just looking for book
recommendations it's a great place to be
wow that's crazy i've read probably five
books this year really
yeah nice well you sound like you don't
believe me i didn't but now i'm like
thinking i can think of four so maybe
you snuck in a fifth
yeah i'll tell you about it later okay
um okay i think that's it again now it's
it
everyone have an amazing weekend sorry
that we won't be here tomorrow but
there's tons of tnn content
and patreon content for you to enjoy
just make sure to have a good weekend
stay safe don't drive drunk wear a mask
you know
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
morning monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cat box all the places so
whenever you listen to podcast find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much we'll see you on monday
have an amazing weekend stay
safe goodbye goodbye